okay last week we had a live caller who
expressed himself maybe in articulately
about the fight for $15 as a minimum
wage and he talked about the possibility
that I guess he said a $15 minimum wage
could be inefficient and it could have
other repercussions that would not be
good in the economy so I thought that it
would be a good opportunity because he
followed up clearly on our reddit
discussion forum I thought it would be a
good opportunity to delve into more
detail about a $15 minimum wage and a
really important starting point when we
talk about the impact of a $15 minimum
wage is to remind you that we are
talking about a $15 minimum wage not a
two hundred dollar minimum wage $200 an
hour minimum wage and that's for a
reason I've explained it before but
there's the slippery slope argument that
some people will make which is hey if a
bigger minimum wage is better and 15 is
better than 12 then why not make it $200
an hour and you can't fall for that
argument when you're talking with people
about the minimum wage a $200 an hour
minimum wage can't be defended in any
serious way it's not an equilibrium wage
by any measure of the economy it's not
an inflation-adjusted wage going back to
you know the creation of the minimum
wage it's not a Productivity adjusted
minimum wage so let's skip the
amateurish slippery slope BS argument of
if a higher minimum wage is good just
raise it even more we are talking
specifically about a $15 minimum wage
there's an argument that is sometimes
made which is you lift the minimum wage
that makes everything get more expensive
and it undoes the impact of the higher
minimum wage and the way it happens is
you raise the minimum wage costs go up
for businesses because they've got to
pay more in payroll
they then account for that by increasing
their prices to avoid going out of
business that disproportionately would
impact small businesses who devote a
bigger share of revenue - payroll than
bigger businesses and are sort of less
able to weather rising costs okay solid
argument right it's a clear argument
increasing the minimum wage causes
inflation and it out does any economic
benefit first of all what is that
argument ignore that argument ignores
that if everybody earned more the
business would likely have more
customers and it depends of course on
the industry but this is one of the main
sort of tenets of supply-side I'm sorry
of demand side stimulus which is people
have more money to spend it businesses
and that's good for businesses the other
issue that's ignored when you say well
you add money to the minimum wage prices
go up by the same amount the problem is
people will make two errors in
calculation one is they'll assume that
if the minimum wage goes up 20% all
businesses have a 20 percent increase to
payroll expenses that's not true though
it only impacts the portion of a
business's employees that earn minimum
wage let me give you an example if the
minimum wage goes from ten to fifteen
dollars an hour that's a fifty percent
increase and then lots of people start
running numbers saying imagine that
payroll costs go up by fifty percent for
all businesses the payroll increase is
only going to be connected to the
portion of employees that earn the
minimum wage if only 20 percent of your
employees earn the minimum wage and it
goes from 12 to 15 dollars that's a 25%
increase only for 20 percent of your
employees which is a fractional increase
to the total payroll expense the other
element to this is that the minimum wage
increase if it's reasonable is going to
be relatively small compared to how much
the prices would have to go up and a
case in point
there was a mcdonald's study I believe
it was McDonald's and I should have
looked it up but I believe it was
McDonald's where it showed that you
could something like double the minimum
wage and that would hit a pretty
significant portion of the employees at
McDonald's but in order to maintain the
same profit they'd only need to raise
the price of a Big Mac by 10 cents why
is that because payroll is only a part
of total costs and minimum wage labor
are only a part of all labor costs
however there's a broader argument
discuss everything I've told you so far
sort of is at the micro level right the
minimum wage change calculation is wrong
the entire analysis other than more
people will have more money to spend is
a micro economic analysis let's think
about this at the macroeconomic level
there's no doubt that some small
businesses would be hurt by higher
minimum wages but consider for a second
the macroeconomic impact the business in
the u.s. is profitable in total doesn't
mean every business is profitable an
increase in the minimum wage will
increase costs at the macroeconomic
level but at the macro level most of
those costs will come out of the huge
business profits that exist it's not
going to put business into the red now
you might say but David here's a
specific business that has a 1 percent
profit margin and that business will go
into the red ok that that's a fair
argument but in total
remember that business is profitable in
the United States profits are
redistributed to the rich through
bonuses for executives when businesses
make big profits salary increases to the
people at the top of the food chain in a
lot of these companies and to
shareholders right when you have profit
in business in publicly traded companies
presumably that profit is redistributed
to people who own shares of stock either
through dividends or through an increase
in the value of company stock that's a
pretty inefficient allocation of funding
those rich people the CEOs that get a
cut of the profit these shareholders who
get dividends they're not gonna spend
most of that extra money they're gonna
put that money away which is not
stimulative to the economy however if
you take some of that profit and you
give it to the employees because of a
higher minimum wage most of that money
is getting spent if you make $28,000 a
year and you get a raise to $29,000 a
year you're likely not putting that
money into the stock market or into a
savings account you're spending that
money
your local community so I think there's
a few issues that are often missed when
people talk about the minimum wage
number one the fact that we ignore the
demand side stimulus of an increase to
the minimum wage number two that the
increased costs can just come out of
profits which will really
disproportionately impact the very rich
you could debate whether that makes
sense but it's hard to argue that that's
not an economically stimulative way to
redistribute money you could say it's
immoral you could say it's their money
let them keep it but the economic
multiplier of demand side stimulus is
significant and that ignores of course
that the payroll costs are only a
fraction of all costs and that minimum
wage payroll is only a fraction of all
payroll so Pat you've been listening to
me rant for a while did I explain this
in a way that it may like your
background is not in economics no but is
am I sort of making sense like do you
have any better understanding of why we
hear a lot of bad arguments I think so
it would also be a good idea for a long
form piece at some point for us and it's
good to point out too that it's not just
those individual workers who are the
beneficiaries of the $15 an hour minimum
wage it's also the economy at large
that's right yeah and you have to it's
very easy to try to tear down some of
these ideas from a micro economic
perspective with very specific examples
from one firm but you've got to remember
business is profitable and we've got to
think about the macro impact here and I
think that this is a good idea actually
for a long-form piece and if I were to
turn this into a long-form piece I would
probably start with a history of the
minimum wage in the United States
because that tells us what would the
current minimum wage be merely if it had
kept up with inflation
what would the minimum wage be if it had
kept up with work or productivity which
has risen even faster in the United
States the cost of living cost of living
is another way that you can adjust the
minimum wage and then we could start
looking into the economic impacts of an
increase to the minimum wage and also I
think it would if we did this as a
long-form piece I would want to tap into
you know you hear from the extreme
libertarians and even I think like
Michelle Bachmann once said there should
be no minimum wage
we have data we have studies that tell
us what would happen if there were no
minimum wage and that would be an
interesting thing to explore as well and
that McDonald's study really sticks out
to me too because if it really is only
10 cents extra per burger I mean who in
their right mind what consumers would
refuse to buy that burger because they
have to pay an extra 10 cents
knowing that every single worker there
is paid $15 an hour well that happened
with Papa John's remember this dude from
Papa John's Pizza who was big against
Obamacare and it ended up coming out
that he would have to add 10 cents to
the price of every single Pizza in order
to give all of his employees health care
so he raised the price by like 15 cents
well I don't know what what he actually
did but when I read that I said wait a
second you're telling me this guy's been
complaining this aggressively about
Obamacare over what would have to be a
10 cent pizza price adjustment to
maintain the exact same profit margins
and I think Forbes looked at that as
well and they're not exactly a left-wing
organization and I think they only found
that it would be 7 cents that case there
was an exaggeration well he was
profiting listen we're rounding up 7 to
10 cents yeah so listen it that most of
these arguments don't make sense and I'm
glad to keep discussing these in detail
and maybe we will look into us look into
this in a long-form format and you can
also participate in the conversation
that already is going on about the $15
minimum wage on our reddit discussion
forum at david pakman.com slash re d di
t the video you just watched was made
possible by support from you please go
to patreon.com slash david pakman show
you can make a pledge of as little as
one dollar per month and every dollar
helps to support the work that we're
doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad